CÇa vient de paraître chez
boboréal.
PoPourquoi la loi 101 est un écc
dede Frédéric Lacroix.
FrFrédéric Lacroix,
auauteur du livre "Pourquoi la i
10101 est t un échec" qui viente
paparaître chez Boréal, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Je ne vais pas inonder les
gegens de chiffres. Vous le savz
vovous avez analysé tout cela. a
lalangue maternelle on le sait l
y y a un déclin du français et n
a a les chiffres jusqu'au
rerecensement de 2016 et on aura
dadans quelques mois le nouveau
rerecensement mais ça baisse. Ça
babaissé en bas du 80 et quand n
reregarde la langue parlée à la
mamaison autre indicateur de 828
onon est à 80,4. C'est une lente
babaisse. Pourquoi vous êtes si
dudur dans votre analyse et vote
coconclusion et pour que vous
ddîtes que la loi 101 est un
écéchec? Tous les enfants de
l'l'immigration qui vont à l'éce
frfrançaise depuis cette loi, n?
- - Il faut se reporter aux
obobjectifs que visait la loi 11
etet ses objectifs sont détaills
dadans le livre blanc de Camille
LaLaurin.
OnOn voulait éviter l'érosion ds
frfrancophones et il voulait
érériger les substitutions
lilinguistiques des allophones
vevers le français. C'était deux
obobjectifs que visait la loi et
sisi on se reporte aujourd'hui x
dodonnées du dernier recensement
dede 2016, on se rend compte que
l'l'érosion annoncée du poids ds
frfrancophones se déroule depuis
1515 ans. Les substitutions
lilinguistiques des allophones t
étété rehaussés. La loi est vene
amaméliorer le statut du franças
mamais pas suffisamment pour
didiriger les substitutions d'ue
fafaçon majoritaire vers le
frfrançais.
- - 100 loi 101, les choses
auauraient été bien pires.
- - Je ne supporterais dire quea
loloi 101 était inutile. Je suis
seseulement en train de dire
ququ'elle n'est pas suffisante
popour qu'il y ait une sécurité
cuculturelle pour les francophos
auau Québec.
- - Vous dîtes que pour aider
cocomme remède il faudrait
s's'attaquer au cégep et à
l'l'enseignement supérieur parce
quque vous dîtes que l'attrait..
onon a un tableau. C'est passé e
2222,4 à 28, : il y a plus de
frfrancophones qui vont étudieru
cécégep en anglais et pourquoi
l'l'autre tableau est la cause e
cece qu'on vient de dire, c'est
ququ'on demande beaucoup une
cocompétence en anglais, 62,9 à
MoMontréal et 40 % dans l'enseme
dudu Québec. Vous dîtes que c'et
çaça qu'il faut freiner.
- - Je ne dis pas qu'il faut
frfreiner l'apprentissage de
l'l'anglais. Je dis que
l'l'apprentissage de l'anglais
chchez les francophones
auaujourd'hui il est répandu et
chchez les francophones qui sont
auau secondaire, la plupart
paparlent déjà anglais. Ils ne
vovont plus haut collégial angls
popour parle anglais, mais il
chchoisisse parce qu'il y a un
prprestige. Ce n'est plus une
ququestion d'aller au cégep pour
apapprendre l'anglais, il parle
dédéjà anglais. Ceux qui sont
sésélectionnés au collégial
ananglais sont déjà déjà capabls
dede parler anglais.
OnOn on pense au collège Dawsonà
MoMontréal. C'est le cégep le ps
prprivé à Montréal. Les gens
veveulent s'y inscrire.
- - C'est l'argument du PQ et du
PaParti libéral et de la CAQ dee
papas inclure les cégeps à la li
10101. Peut-être qu'il parle
ananglais à l'entrée, mais ils
vovont parler et écrire l'anglas
bebeaucoup mieux l'anglais à la
sosortie d'un cégep anglophone.
- - Je ne suis pas sûr que le
niniveau d'anglais qu'ils ont à
l'l'entrée soient déficients. Je
pepense que l'anglais accapare s
jejeunes francophones surtout cx
ququi vont au cégep en anglais
sosont des finissants de l'école
prprivée. Ils ont un excellent
niniveau d'anglais. Je ne suis s
ssûr que c'est nécessaire de
l'l'améliorer encore.
- - Que faudrait-il faire
mamaintenant pour redresser les
chchoses?
- - Il faudrait tenter de revenr
àà la loi 100 original. Il
fafaudrait que des actes
imimportants et de faire du
frfrançais la langue de l'État
ququébécois. Actuellement l'État
ququébécois est devenu un état
bibilingue dans les faits. Il
ofoffre le choix de la langue
d'd'intégration aux immigrants.n
a a suivi le fédéral.
JeJe pense que l'éducation c'est
lele nerf de la guerre parce que
ququand on a conçu la loi 101, e
didiplôme d'études secondaires
ététait le diplôme le plus remis
auau Québec. Les études
cocollégiales étaient encore
seseulement le fait d'une minoré
etet maintenant, les études
cocollégiales sont rendues au me
niniveau que le diplôme d'études
sesecondaires. Il y a autant de
didiplôme d'études collégiales e
dede diplômes d'études secondais
sosont remis. Le poste secondai,
lele cégep et les universités,
jojouent un rôle de plus en plus
imimportant dans la formation
pepersonnelle.
- - Ils ne vont pas imposer la i
10101 au cégep complètement. Ils
vovont limiter l'accès à certais
frfrancophones en jouant sur les
ququotas. Est-ce que d'emblée vs
didites que ça va être cosmétiqe
etet ce ne sera pas suffisant?
- - C'est le seuil minimal
atatteindre pour que le projet e
loloi soit vraiment porteur et e
pepense qu'il y a des mesures qi
sosont importantes mais il y a
auaussi le signal que le projete
loloi voit envoyer. Ce signal dt
êêtre fort à l'effet que le
frfrançais revient la langue de
réréférence au Québec. Ça prend
unune mesure symbolique forte. e
prprojet de loi n'est pas public
enencore et je ne sais pas quele
sesera cette mesure, mais ça en
prprend une.
- - Qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avavec vos conclusions, c'est ue
lelecture intéressante et c'estn
dédébat qu'on va ouvrir au Québe